you know and I think a lot about
independence I think you know a lot of
people ask me about like oh you know do
you when you're gonna do a Netflix
special when you're gonna do this when
are you gonna do a special and I think
about that but I think about you know I
mean there's been offers for a special
for a stand-up comedy special but I
think about this what if you sell a
special to a platform you know in a
platform that's like Netflix or Amazon
or you know Comedy Central a different
place if one day they decide they don't
like your voice being in the world which
sounds maybe they wouldn't people say
well maybe they wouldn't do that or it
might not
well if one day they do if you sell them
something
then this there's they owned it so they
could press a button and you off you're
off the docket you know you your your
your your voice doesn't even exist
anymore and when I see sometimes you
know a lot of times I mean they haven't
even put you know I feel like if some of
these places I haven't even put somebody
from you know like a rural person on
television in or on you know giving them
some opportunities in a long time so it
makes me think well what if they just
decide oh we don't like this this guy's
voice anymore then week they can
eliminate it if they own it so I just
think about that you know I think about
that well once I sell something to them
they own it and they could delete it
when they want to and that I don't exist
you know so it's it's just a battle
sometimes to think well do I just want
to stay independent and just this way I
know that no matter what you you know
right or wrong no matter what choices I
make or decisions I make even if some of
them are ok and some were not okay
someone else doesn't get to say oh well
we didn't like this choice this person
made in their life or this thing they
did and we don't like their voice being
out there and we can take them off of
our platform and since we own their
voice since we own what they sold us
then the mess that they're gone
and some of you might say well that's
kind of crazy to think about but I don't
know if it is I mean it seems like
people's voices can get muted a lot of
times these days if they're owned by
someone else so I just you know I think
about independence I think about you
know I mean America was founded people
wanted to be independent I mean things
you know things was going so bad in
britain some people got into a boat and
left and the people in Britain were like
where are you going and they're like we
don't know I mean that's crazy things
must have been really rocky if you left
and didn't even know where you were
going and only had just a couple
sandwiches a couple of you know decent
chicks which II didn't even have
something eating having real you know
amazing batch you know a couple
cauldrons of soup or whatever gunpowder
that gunpowder chowder but that's what
they were eating back then
I mean you needed something you could
you know you could pop off and then
something you could fill your gullet and
something that you could you know that
you could fill your musket you that
gunpowder chat or something that you
know you needed that that that
double-edge meal you know that way you
could use it to fight you could use it
to feast but that's crazy independence
you know so yeah people asked about that
about being independent and what I think
about it and about doing a special and
that's one of the things that kind of
holds me up sometimes it's just some
thing where I don't want to be owned by
someone I don't want someone to own me
where one day they could say well we
don't really want your voice out there
so you know we don't like your kind I
mean I feel enough of that when I even
got out here to Hollywood we don't you
know oh you sound this way you're not
really well you know I just you know
it's kind of left a sour taste in my
mouth oh you don't have I don't know man
you know they think everybody where I'm
from is a just a racist or a an idiot
you know they think a lot of rural white
people or rural people at all or just
ignorant you know and it just I don't
know man I've never really felt super
welcome and now some of that could be my
own fault maybe sometimes I don't want
to be welcome you know maybe there's
something inside of me that that would
that that doesn't want to be welcomed I
mean maybe I'm people could lay out a
hundred welcome mats and maybe I
wouldn't notice it but I do notice when
people's voices get silenced if they're
not a certain way and I don't think my
voice is that but who knows in ten years
from now if that's what people if you
know somebody has some companies like
man this this guy doesn't think like
either way same exact way I think about
everything so we got to get it you know
let's take them off the platform then
you're going so I don't know I just
think about that kind of stuff sometimes
you know you work so hard to create your
own voice to just try and stay
independent and just do your own thing
and then something comes along and you
know I don't know it's like the snail
man I mean you don't even know that
snail doesn't even know he he'll trudge
his whole life to get 40 feet but then
his son you know his son he might have a
little bit at 39 feet he might you know
slug up with another little bedbug and
then they got didn't they have a baby
and that baby goes you know the next
generation he goes that next 40 feet and
then the next generation goes the next
40 feet and they just keep going you
know
it takes a couple of legs to get
somewhere it takes a couple of
generations to get somewhere you know if
you riding that independence you got a
really sometimes you got to ride it out
so anyway I'm not saying that I wouldn't
do a comedy special with another group
or something like that but I really you
know I have a tough time thinking about
being um about my artwork and stuff
being owned by somebody or my stories I
mean and maybe I'm overthinking things
that's fine but you know I can't help
the way that I think you know all the
times the way that I think this is just
you know I'm kind of sentenced kind of
stuck here in this I mean some people's
brain this really makes perfect sense
you got that cucumber you got them them
too modest boy but then damn boy I got
this I got this jar relish up here Wow
you know what's crazy as my sister can't
even read but what does it have to do
with us right now hope you enjoyed that
video and you can watch another and you
can watch this one you can watch this
one different options different choices
some guy just brings you one option not
this guy two options watch one that's
what I guess what